[Musik]
unser hammer der woche das
unterfränkische geiselwind direkt an der
viel befahrenen a 3 gelegen hat nach
jahrzehntelangem kampf endlich ein
lärmschutzwall bekommen
doch gerade erst fertig muss er jetzt
direkt wieder abgerissen werden weil das
ding nicht feststeht greift hier die
schaufel und der metallzaun wird
zerschnitten in geiselwind kann man gar
nicht glauben was da gerade passiert so
was heute in der auch in der zeit
vorkommen dass man so an pfusch am bau
macht der 40 noch mal der kleine mann
sollte es wieder dachte jetzt ist fertig
jetzt ist alles gut und jetzt heißt soll
das ist alles noch mal neu gemacht
werden muss so blöd für alle denke ich
vor fünf jahren baut die autobahn gmbh
des bundes endlich den lärmschutzwall an
der a3 bei geiselwind oben auf den ball
soll noch eine vier meter hohe acrylglas
wand doch vor ein paar wochen dann die
späte erkenntnis der ganze berg ist
instabil die steinwand hat sich verformt
die acrylglas wand kann deshalb hier
nicht drauf gesetzt werden das würde
nicht lange halten ein großer teil des
walds sandsteinmauer kommt also wieder
weg und muss danach noch mal komplett
neu aufgebaut werden
in geiselwind ärgern sich die menschen
über den neuerlichen lärm und dreck der
bürgermeister wundert sich über den
sorglosen umgang mit öffentlichen
geldern und dann gibt es bestimmt
regressforderungen aber wie lange dauert
so ein verfahren das kann jahre dauern
kann im sande verlaufen und der
steuerzahler muss das bezahlen
unverständlich und tatsächlich bei der
autobahn gmbh des bundes heisst es die
kosten für die reparaturarbeiten zahle
erstmal die staatskasse und dann für den
durch die mangelhafte bauausführung
entstandenen schaden wird die autobahn
gmbh des bundes entsprechende
schadensersatzforderungen an die
seinerzeit ausführende firma stellen
dass das erfolgreich sein wird daran
glaubt in der lärmgeplagten
marktgemeinde geiselwind kaum jemand
erst am schluss bilden mängel auftreten
dann merkt man persönlich ist was falsch
gelaufen und haben jetzt natürlich immer
teuer und wertz wir steuerzahler geld ja
nicht
und wieder nix denn soviel architekten
und planungen sind die jahrelang sind
die ingenieure sind dran dann dass so
etwas nicht passieren
mittlerweile hat der bund eine neue
baufirma beauftragt die will den ball
noch in diesem jahr komplett reparieren
der rechtsstreit darüber wer den ganzen
spaß zahlen wird der wird wohl noch
jahre dauern